notre question qui est intéressante dans
le convoi dans les parrainages
aujourd'hui et qui qu'on peut parler
aujourd'hui ici grt grâce à l'excellent
travail qui a été fait c'est qu'elle est
la catégorie socioprofessionnelle des
parrains de chaque candidat mon intérêt
c'est vrai grâce à ce merveilleux qui a
été fait on voit que ça recoupe et 20
essentiellement ce que l'électorat de
chaque candidat évidemment qu emmanuel
macron lui pour l'instant dans les
parent qui l'a comparé à déclarer est
quelqu'un qui recueille évidemment
beaucoup plus parmi les maires et autres
élus de cadres et professions
intellectuelles supérieures
c'est le cas aussi de valérie pécresse
alors qu on échange on voit qu'une
marine le pen évidemment est beaucoup
plus soutenu par des élus et des mères
qui sont des intermédiaires san jose en
gros le poujadisme si on peut dire et
puis pour jean luc mélenchon on voit
professions intellectuelles professions
intermédiaires donc oui c'est vrai que
chaque parrainage donne un peu déjà la
couleur du candidat et puis il ya aussi
autre chose c'est que plus de 71% de ses
signataires des parrainages sont des
hommes du fait de la structure de
l'électorat local en france donc il ya
aussi ce biais là et je peux voir que
par le parrainage déjà on donne une
couleur à un candidat c'est peut-être
important et c'est peut-être une bonne
chose justement ça permet déjà de nous
diversifier le l'accompagnent